défi communiste ou communisants vérité
d'hommes semblables niveau
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
etienne cofondateur de scopeo et je vous
souhaite la bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de notre entrevue politique
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'épisode 6 et
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
d'amiante en allemagne pour discuter
écologie etc au modernisme décroissance
et politique gouvernementale aujourd'hui
je suis en compagnie de lucas bonjour
lucas bonjour etienne et bonjour à vous
monsieur d'amérique kunselman bonjour à
vous bonjour à ceux qui nous écoutent
donc comme etienne a introduit on a on a
le plaisir de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
pour parler d'écologie et pour trouver
des voies qui nous permettront de
répondre à la crise environnementale que
nous traversons en effet le thème de cet
entretien va porter sur l'éco modernisme
une vision que vous défendez vous même
dans votre groupe de réflexion qui
s'appelle construire l'avenir
mais avant de démarrer l'entrevue damien
kudzman je vous laisse vous présenter
brièvement et présenté également votre
s'il tente que construire l'avenir
eh bien d'abord enchanté merci beaucoup
de m'avoir invité donc moi je m'appelle
des maps aux hellman étudiant en droit
et en économie tout ce qui est plus
basique et j'ai fondé un think-tank donc
qui s'appelle contre l'avenir et qui
vise à concilier la croissance
économique à l'impératif de préservation
de l'environnement
donc on avance un peu à rebours de la
doxa écologique dominante c'est à dire
monopolisé par les idées de décroissance
et c'est pour essayer de construire un
cadre où on puisse à la fois se
développer économiquement et
technologiquement et en même temps
réussir à préserver l'environnement
ce faisant nous sommes évidemment plutôt
en faveur du nucléaire en faveur des ogm
est en faveur de toutes les technologies
qui peuvent nous permettre de répondre
aux changements climatiques
nous avons donc fondé notre groupe de
réflexion il ya à peu près un an et demi
donc on a eu des périodes plus active
que d'autres en ce moment on est un peu
dans une palette de mou mais on compte
revenir très bientôt avec
un format d'émission un peu semblable à
la vôtre et on compte invité de nombreux
de nombreux experts dans les domaines
environnementaux dans les domaines
politiques pour discuter
toujours autour de la thématique de
l'environnement et de la croissance
économique très bien bd déjà merci pour
cette pour cette représentation vous
souhaite bien évidemment bon courage
pour le lancement de votre merci
beaucoup
alors moi j'aimerais qu'on commence par
revenir sur un terme et qu au modernisme
chez ce copé on aime beaucoup les gens
qui se définissent politiquement on aime
beaucoup les idées on aime beaucoup de
débats d'idées et moi je voulais
peut-être commencer par se moquer ce que
c'est un écho aux modernistes
qu'est ce que cette doctrine politique
sous-tend est ce que d'ailleurs c'est
seulement une doctrine écologique ou
est-ce qu'il s'agit aussi d'une intrigue
politique alors l'écho modernisme c'est
un mot qui nous vient tout droit des
etats-unis qui a été théorisée par an
premier michael shannon vergeur donc qui
est le maître à penser de l'éco
modernisme aux états unis ce mot s'est
peu à peu exporté en france même s'il
aujourd'hui quand même assez minoritaire
est défini une philosophie
environnementale comme je les dis où on
va essayer de concilier la croissance
économique
et je dirais la préservation de
l'environnement dont l'écho modernisme
échos pour l'économie modernisme pour la
modernité et qu ayant à la fois deux
sens le mot économie le mot écologie
donc l'écho modernisme tout est dans le
nom c'est l'alliance entre l'économie et
l'écologie
autrement dit comment créer sur terre
les bases d'une
d'une société qui soit prospère qui soit
en croissance sans pour autant que cette
société soit néfaste pour son
environnement
donc comment se développer sans puiser
trop de ressources naturelles comment se
développer sans une hausse fulgurante
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
toutes ces questions donc c'est essayer
de traiter les échos moderniste donc le
mot éco moderniste et n'est donc comme
je l'avais dit qu'ils avaient écrit avec
d'autres chercheurs manifestent donc le
manifeste de diego modernisme que vous
pouvez retrouver très facilement en
ligne et qui pose en fait les bases de
la philosophie en écho moderniste parce
qu'avant d'être un domaine très
technique c'est surtout une philosophie
environnementale manière de penser
l'avenir
une manière de penser notre rapport à la
terre notre rapport à l'environnement
est une manière de penser dans la
société et les rapports que la société
doit entretenir avec l'environnement et
avec les autres espèces
donc on a beaucoup on a beaucoup comment
dire on a beaucoup rapprochés le coc
modernisme avec le clan duclos pianisme
qui est une philosophie qui est une une
théorie sur laquelle la croissance
humaine mènerait à la croissance des
ressources donc à rebours du
malthusianisme qui est lui prône la
verse
mais le néo colonialisme n'est pas
vraiment alors évidemment il peut se
rapprocher du tourisme mais il différent
dans le sens où nous ne sommes pas
toujours extrêmement positif sur
l'avenir de l'humanité
nous pensons simplement qu'il est
possible de se développer tout en axe
tout en en diminuant de gaz à effet de
serre tout en optimisant l'entreprise
sur l'environnement
mais pour autant les échos modernisme
sont quand même conscient qu'il ya un
certain nombre de limites qui s'imposent
à nous des limites en termes de
ressources des limites en terme d'
espaces et donc ce qui est ce que je
joue vraiment intéressant dans la
logique éco moderniste c'est que nous ne
sommes pas des techno bea qui voulons à
tout prix nous développer et pour
l'environnement
mais au contraire on essaie vraiment de
se poser dans un cadre où on essaie de
réfléchir sur les limites
on essaie de définir les limites on
essaie de voir comment les repousser ou
les contourner ou comment composer avec
je sais pas si ça répond parfaitement
réaliste oui merci merci dame raconte
damon pour cette première définition qui
nous permet de poser les bases de la
théorie et comme modern hits qui comme
etienne le disait un peu en vogue
finalement dans le débat public et dans
les médias et maintenant on va on va
plutôt entrer dans le vif du sujet on va
passer directement au volet économique
si vous le voulez bien
car il semble évident que en fait le
péril écologique que nous commençons à
vivre et qui nous attend est directement
liée à notre modèle économique et à nos
modes de production
déjà on va poser ses premières bases si
vous êtes d'accord et ensuite la
question qui qui qui suit ce premier
développement est ce que vous croyez
réellement au système capitaliste pour
répondre aux problématiques écologiques
de notre époque
est ce que finalement vous croyez à la
théorie du capitalisme vert et
responsable
alors j'ai déjà un problème avec le mot
capitalisme qui est assez galvaudé et
qui est quand même connoté négativement
dans l'opinion publique mais est ce que
je pense que l'économie de marché peut
aider à résoudre la crise
environnementale
je pense que oui et je sais que c'est un
point de vue qui va à rebours de la
pensée dominante mais où je pense déjà
que les économies socialiste n'excelle
pas particulièrement par leur en prit
son environnement
alors sans vouloir tomber dans des
propos qui ce cas caricaturaux l'urss
ils mettaient beaucoup de gaz à effet de
serre le venezuela y met beaucoup de gaz
à effet de serre donc je pense que le
problème n'est pas vraiment le
capitalisme en tant que tel le problème
c'est la production le problème c'est
comment réussir à produire sans émettre
de gaz à effet de serre l'écho
modernisme peut s'inscrire dans un cadre
capitaliste comme dans un cadre
communiste
au final qu'est ce qui les différencie
alors évidemment les échos moderniste se
retrouve plutôt généralement dans des
milieux libéraux mais le problème de
ceux qui causent la crise
environnementale n'est pas tant le
capitalisme que la production que le
consumérisme et je ne pense pas qu'il
faille à tout prix vouloir revenir sur
les bases de l'économie de marché je ne
pense pas que nationaliser d'entreprise
et je ne pense pas que mais de faire la
propriété privée pourra aider à pourra
aider l'environnement et je pense que et
là on est plutôt dans le cadre de
l'utopie donc moi je crois au
capitalisme vert comme je crois à la
croissance verte
parce que tout simplement je pense que
le problème est ailleurs je pense que le
problème n'est pas fondamentalement dans
le système économique mais tout
simplement dans la manière de produire
et je pense que une économie capitaliste
comme une économie communiste peut créer
une centrale nucléaire peut électrifier
des usines peut électrifier des
véhicules peut développer des méthodes
d'extraction des minéraux qui serait
plus respectueuse de l'environnement
voilà donc je pense que oui je suis pour
la capitalisme vert parce que je pense
que le problème est ailleurs
très bien alors
bien revenir sur une notion qui
m'intéresse beaucoup vous avez parlé du
copernic analystes si je me trompe pas
voyez vous l'avez comparer avec l'écho
modernisme en disant que finalement la
peut-être il ya un point différence
c'est sur le pessimisme ou plutôt le oui
disons le pessimisme humain que vous
admettez un peu plus vous n'êtes pas
dans une forme d'utopie scientifique
oui c'est si je me trompe pas vous avez
quand même une vision optimiste sur
l'évolution de la science
et c'est là et c'est là moi que j'ai un
point important mais je me trompe
peut-être mais il me semble qu'il ya
quand même chez vous une forme de vision
rédemptrice de la science c'est à dire
la science va nous sauver ou ou d'une
certaine manière le progrès scientifique
va nous sauver
moi je compare ça l'imminence de la
crise écologique certains me disent peu
importe leur spectre optique d'ailleurs
que c'est parfois trop tard alors
comment être certain que c'est inventé
scientifiques puissent justement nous
sortir de l'impasse dans laquelle nous
sommes
quid de la prédictibilité du progrès
scientifique oui surtout pour quelles
avancées vous conter et dans les années
dans les décennies qui viennent pour
nous sortir de cette impasse climatique
alors c'est une question qui est très
intéressante parce que ça revient à nous
demander au fond si notre point de vue
ne serait pas aussi utopique il te piste
est ce que on ne parierait pas sur des
technologies à venir
est-ce qu'on 9 ans tu as n'aurait pas
sur l'avenir risque au final on ferait
pas le risque de prendre un pari très
risqué
je pense que c'est une question
intéressante et je pense que c'est une
question qu'on s'est posée dès le début
lorsqu'on a créé contre l'avenir et
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai c'est de parler le plus possible
que ce soit sur les réseaux sociaux ou
sur notre site ou sur le vidéo de
technologies qui existent déjà
parce que au final on a tendance à
sous-estimer l'état actuel de nos
technologies on a tendance à
sous-estimer l'état actuel des moyens
que nous pouvons mettre en oeuvre pour
régler la crise climatique et au final
quand on regarde l'étendue des possibles
qui s'ouvre à nous au niveau de nos
technologies actuelles on se rend compte
que et là on peut faire beaucoup de
choses
donc évidemment on est optimiste du
point de vue du développement
technologique
moi à titre personnel je pense par
exemple que la fusion nucléaire pourra
régler une grande partie de nos
problèmes d'ici 2050 2100 mais je ne me
base pas sur ça dans mes travaux et je
ne base pas sur ça dans mes écrits
j'essaie de me baser au maximum sur des
technologies qui existent déjà par
exemple les réacteurs nucléaires de
génération actuelle
l'exploitation de l'uranium marin qui
existe déjà un peu évidemment les
technologies ne sont pas encore comment
dire étendu à un niveau industriel c'est
encore balbutiant mais on a des procédés
que nous maîtrisons déjà
donc il ne reste plus qu'à les ados
scalise et et qu'elle allait mettre en
oeuvre à grande échelle
donc oui le lait communisme est une
forme de pari sur l'avenir
mais on essaie quand même de rester
lucide et on essaie quand même de ceux
basés au maximum sur des technologies
qui existent déjà bien sûr évidemment on
va on parfois prospecter un peu
prospecter un peu l'avenir mais c'est ce
n'est pas en tout cas là dessus que
repose la la majeure partie de nos
propos alors je me permet de rebondir
avant que louis la continue moi ce que
j'en tire c'est qu'il ya quand même pas
et vous le dit très bien un pari sur
l'avenir
il ya une idée de dire on joue un peu au
poker si je me trompe pas alors moi ma
question parce que je suis un peu naïf
mais est ce qu'on peut se permettre
vu l'urgence des choses qui se profile
devant nous de faire un pari ces
questions qui volontairement un peu
un peu taquiné mais je pense que c'est
une vraie question qu'il faut se poser
je pense que quelle que soit l'option
que nous privilégierons on fera un pari
ici on optait pour la décroissance on
fait un pari sur le fait que qu'il soit
possible des rues dans l'entreprise sur
l'environnement venir à la décroissance
juste après d'accord bas je ne vais pas
trop rogner sur le sujet mais quelle que
soit la solution qu'on va vous tenir au
final on fera un pari sur l'avenir
donc les co modernisme et une forme de
pari sur l'avenir
mais c'est pas un pari si gasquet que ça
dans le sens où on observe la situation
actuelle on observe les technologies
actuelles et avec les technologies
actuelles on peut déjà faire beaucoup de
choses on sait déjà électrifié
l'extraction minière ans électrifier les
transports ans électricien les les
légines industriels on sait on sait
faire plein de choses
donc oui c'est une forme de pari sur
l'avenir mais j'aimerais qu'on soit un
peu moins pessimistes sur l'état du
monde et que on se rendre compte que
évidemment pour régler les problèmes qui
sont ceux qui vont qui vont apparaître
on va avoir besoin d'un certain nombre
d'innovations mais on a déjà beaucoup de
clés en main donc plutôt que de faire un
pari j'ai envie de dire soyons honnêtes
chrono en main les technologiques que
nous avons à disposition développons les
achats l'industriel et utilisons les
et bien maintenant comme comédienne l'a
annoncé à quelques minutes on va parler
un petit peu de décroissance donc je
reviens en fait sur règles sur le volet
économique et moi j'ai bien compris en
fait en parcourant votre site en
parcourant les travaux de votre groupe
de réflexion construire l'avenir que
venait pas adepte vous même de la
théorie de la décroissance et des
discours quelque peu pessimiste sur
l'avenir de la société humaine donc
maintenant j'ai besoin de savoir qu'est
ce que vous préconisez pour engager une
véritable transition écologique qui
s'avère nécessaire parce que sans pour
autant prôner une décroissance absolue
et on sait que la croissance économique
dans sa forme actuelle et capitaliste
même si vous aimez pas forcément ce
moment mais en tout cas dans le dans
l'économie de marché on va dire que s'il
faut être lucide elle nuit quelque peu à
l'environnement elle nuit elle épuise
notre planète en détruisant des
ressources non renouvelables comme les
matières premières
elle dégrade les écosystèmes à
l'appauvrir la biodiversité elles
perturbent le climat est conduit à la
hausse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ce sont des sujets et j'en doute
pas que vous connaissez parfaitement
bien alors comment peut-on vraiment
réorienter la croissance économique vers
une voie un peu plus éthique et plus
respectueuse de notre environnement
alors c'est aussi une question
intéressante mais je pense que votre
action de base est un peu erronée
je pense que la croissance ne mène pas
forcément à une hausse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre elle valait même
pas forcément à une hotte dégradation
environnementale via un certain nombre
de travaux aujourd'hui scientifique qui
tendent à nous montrer que qui tendent à
confirmer la théorie qui avait énoncé
enfin dans une forme différente cuisine
est à savoir que la croissance est comme
çà mau découplage ça voilà c'est le
découplage c'est l'idée que la
croissance économique va nuire à
l'environnement jusqu'à un certain point
d'inflexion à partir duquel plus de
croissance égale moins de co2 alors ça
marche avec la déforestation ça marche
avec plein de choses on a de l'argent on
peut observer en france que jusqu'en
haute aller jusque dans les années 1850
on avait tendance à beaucoup déforester
et la superficie boisée cessé de
diminuer
alors que depuis 1850 on a observé un
grand tournant et aujourd'hui nos
surfaces boisées ne cesse d'augmenter
on a aussi observé au niveau des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
notamment du co2 je vous invite vraiment
aller voir sur le site de as well in
data qui fournit des données extrêmement
intéressante et qui nous montre que donc
pays par pays
les émissions et l'impact de la
croissance sur les émissions et alors on
va me répondre que certes par exemple
aux états unis les émissions ont pu
baisser et on a pu avoir une situation
de croissance économique donc mais à
quel prix parce qu'on a je me fais
l'avocat du diable
mais ces partitions d'accès puisse leur
démission
c'est ça c'est ce que j'allais dire et
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup
l'outil c'est parce qu'il prend en
compte les émissions importés et c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait assez peu dans
le débat public mais qui est quand même
primordial parce que effectivement si on
aimait mois mais qu'on consomme beaucoup
de produits importés de chine
fabriqués dans des conditions
extrêmement polluantes c'est un peu de
la triche mais on se rend compte que
même en prenant en compte les émissions
apportez donc autrement dit en regardant
les émissions du point de vue de la
consommation et non pas de la production
eh bien on se rend compte que les gaz à
effet de serre notamment en france ont
tendance à baisser
en dépit de la croissance économique et
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve dans
plein de pays dans plein de pays
développés donc je pense que la
croissance économique nuit à
l'environnement
jusqu'à un certain point et je pense que
dans nos pays occidentaux - de
croissance ne serait pas forcément
positif du point de vue environnemental
parce que comment voulez-vous électrifié
nos usines nos transports ce qui on n'a
pas de point investir
comment google peuvent-ils faire tourner
leur datacenter aux verts s'ils n'ont
plus un rond pour parler de la
caricature donc mais si je me permets de
sur votre première question quand
j'avais parlé d'économie et du système
capitaliste vous aviez dit évidemment
que le sujet n'était pas forcément la
croissance économique et le système
capitaliste en lui-même mais nos modes
de production
alors ça c'est une réponse intéressante
mais comment si vous voulez on va pas
forcément parler de croissance
économique mais on va parler de
production alors comment justement on
réoriente notre production et comment on
favorise une production moins polluantes
alors il ya beaucoup de moyens de le
faire et les échos des modernistes sont
quand même assez partagés sur le sujet
certains sont en faveur de quotas
carbone
certains sont en faveur d'une taxe
carbone ça atteint sont en faveur tout
simplement due aux investissements dans
les domaines vert il ya tout un tas de
possibles qui s'ouvre à nous il ya tout
un tas d'outils de régulation qui
peuvent être mises en oeuvre pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir comment dire pour
pouvoir
mais c'est notre empreinte de co2 pour
pouvoir favoriser les productions à
faible coût carbone
moi personnellement je suis plutôt en
faveur de l'idée des quotas carbone
individualisé avec un marché carbone
on a un certain nombre de boutiques de
régulation économique qui vont nous
permettre de favoriser les produits à
faible coût environnemental donc que ce
soit la taxe carbone que ce soit le
quotas carbone individualisé il ya plein
de choses qui peuvent nous permettre de
contraindre le marché et de d'amener le
marché vers une situation qui serait
plus favorable du point de vue
environnemental
alors après l'état a aussi son rôle à
jouer notamment en fournissant les
infrastructures dédiées par exemple en
créant des bornes de recharge électrique
pour les véhicules électriques en créant
en investissant massivement dans le
nucléaire
en investissant massivement dans les
énergies renouvelables où elles sont
utiles en investissant massivement dans
la captation carbone donc je pense que
on a un couple à mettre en oeuvre qui
est des investissements massifs de
l'état et des outils de régulation du
marché qui pourrait nous permettre
d'améliorer notre situation actuelle de
ce pont bull très bien alors pour moi
j'ai une autre question
après on viendra peut-être un peu plus
tard sur la politique énergétique du
gouvernement mais j'avais quand même
envie de poser cette question peut être
une réponse rapide puisque c'est une
question assez simple est ce que pour
vous moi je pense une délectation j'ai
lu quelques jours dans une tribune dont
je me rappelle pas l'auteur isolé qui
disait de manière extrêmement frustrante
si tous les hommes sur terre vivait
comme un occidental moyen
notre modèle s'écroule est ce que cette
affirmation simple pour vous elle est
vraie et si oui est-ce qu'elles entrent
pas un peu quand même en contradiction
avec la vision etc aux modernistes qui
suivent manquant vous utilisiez juste
avant met de côté le l'hypothèse
décroissante
alors cette citation est un peu
caricatural parce que tout le monde
toute la terre ne va pas du jour au
lendemain au revoir le mode de vie d'un
occidental
c'est sûr que si du jour au lendemain
tout le monde vivait comme un occidental
mais sans qu'on dispose des
infrastructures productives les
infrastructures technologiques
d'infrastructures sociales pour
accompagner
cette hausse de vie est évidemment qu'on
aurait des problèmes maintenant c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche
ce que j'observe c'est que l'humanité a
tendance à améliorer son niveau de vie
et que l'amélioration de ce niveau de
vie ne se fait pas forcément à rebours
de la protection de l'environnement
donc je comprends je comprends
l'interrogation que vous me poser mais
je pense que déjà l'axiome un peu
réducteur et un peu simpliste et je
pense qu'il est tout à fait possible de
faire coexister sur la terre 8 milliards
d'êtres humains avec l'état de nos
ressources donc avec les ressources dont
nous disposons les technologies dont
nous disposons je ne pense pas qu'il
soit fondamentalement impossible que
nous vivions tous un mode de vie qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient relativement
agréable qui soit prospère
on observe que plus le mode de vie sain
plus le niveau de vie d'une population a
tendance à augmenter plus son niveau
comment dire plus on son accès aux
ressources m'attendre est de favoriser
donc autrement dit plus on est riche
plus on va dans des facilités à accéder
aux sources donc plus on est riche plus
on a des ressources pour parler un peu
pour parler un peu cru c'est l' indice
de celanese de simon si si si je ne me
trompe pas qui est qui qui évalue l'état
de ressources par rapport à notre mode
de vie et la croissance de la population
donc je pense que nous avons encore
beaucoup de marge et je pense surtout
que nous avons tendance à sous-estimer
les ressources dont nous disposons et je
pense vraiment que c'est dû à un certain
nombre d'indicateurs un peu malhonnête
là tout de suite quand vous me dîtes si
tout le monde vivait comme un occidental
notre système s'écroulerait je pense
tout de suite à la très fameuse théorie
du jour du dépassement
c'est des phrases qu'on entend chaque
année si toute l'humanité vivait comme
un français on aurait besoin de cinq
planètes terre pour subvenir à nos
besoins
bon petit aparté sur sur ce jour du
dépassement on ne prend en compte que
les émissions carbone
on ne parle pas de ressources à
proprement parler a précédé sujet que
j'ai déjà traité c'est pas vraiment le
sujet ici mais tout ça pour dire que je
peux pas vraiment commenter cette
affirmation parce qu'elle ne repose sur
rien si ce n'est sur une vérité et non c
gepa les sources
j'ai pas le raisonnement de l'auteur moi
je pourrai répondre je pourrai répondre
par exemple en disant regardez on a
encore tel et tel milliards de tonnes de
cuivre
on a télétel milliards de tonnes
d'aluminium on a encore ça on attelle
substitut pour tel matériau mais voilà
je peux pas y répondre
si ce n'est en vous disant ce que je
vous ai déjà dit que je ne pense pas que
ce soit vrai et que je pense qu'on a
encore largement de la marche alors où
c'est bien vous avez cité le sujet du
jour du dépassement qui fait souvent la
une des médias quand les études
paraissent public et et moi ça me permet
de rebondir en fait sur ce sujet qui
revient également à la production à nos
modes de production comment on peut
concilier le fait que par exemple comme
vous le lieu comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure un français il faudrait être au
cal période même si évidemment ces cds
des données qui peuvent être remises en
question mais comment on peut concilier
le fait que les occidentaux le mode de
vie occidental ne correspond pas à la
crise écologique qu'on traverse avec le
fait que tous les pays en développement
économique on pense également à la chine
qui semble beaucoup plus en voix de
d'expansion économique que les autres
pays en croissance
comment on peut concilier le fait que
les autres pays les autres populations
aspirent également à ce mode de vie mais
on peut pas en fait on peut pas leur
interdire de vouloir également inspiré
ce mode de vie qui est assez luxueuse et
confortable mais alors comment on fait
alors c'est encore une fois une question
intéressante et je pense que le problème
n'est pas en soi dans le mode de vie ou
dans le niveau de vie mais dans la
manière d'assurer la production qui nous
permet d'atteindre ce niveau de vie
autrement dit je pense que l'on peut
très bien garder notre niveau de vie
tout en diminuant d'entreprendre son
environnement
je t'ai déjà dit pour plein de sujets
que ce soit via une électrification
pardon massive de nos moyens de
production que ce soit via le recours à
des énergies beaucoup moins carbonée je
pense que je pense qu'on peut très bien
nous occidentaux conserver voire même
amélioré nos modes de vie sans forcément
qu'en parallèle on aggrave notre
empreinte sur l'environnement
maintenant je vais vous dire à titre
personnel je suis plutôt pessimiste sur
la capacité de l'humanité à répondre aux
changements climatiques notamment vous
nommez cité l'exemple de la chine tous
les pays en voie de développement sont
on connaissent des croissances
économiques assez forte connaissent des
situations où voilà on ne peut pas
demander à des gens qui ne savent pas
s'ils vont pouvoir manger la semaine
prochaine de se poser la question des
générations futures.dans sentant 200 à
300 ans
donc moi je pense que les pays
occidentaux doivent mener la route que
les pays occidentaux doivent
considérablement à diminuer leurs
émissions que les pays occidentaux
doivent aussi quelque part aider
notamment technologiquement les pays en
voie de développement
mais je pense et je suis assez je pense
qu réaliste sur le sujet je pense qu'on
dépassera de loin l'objectif qui avait
été fixé par l'accord de paris donc je
sais pas si ça répond parfaitement à
votre question suis je
je pense qu'on est dans ceux ci je pense
que vous avez bien répondu moi je me
permet de rebondir
on va parler peut-être un peu
métapolitique théorie politique
ce que je note quand même quelque chose
je me suis tu je ne me trompe pas vous
êtes vous proclamez de manière
d'ailleurs assez assez courageuse
libéral puis son interview aujourd'hui
et très galvaudé donc c'est intéressant
alors je je je
j'imagine que le planisme écologique et
n'est pas dans vos réponses envisagées à
l'échelle nationale ou internationale et
je suis suis assez d'accord avec vous
mais je note quand même qu'il existe une
forme de contradiction assez
intéressante
moi ce que je vois avec cette crise
écologique c'est que vous qui êtes quand
même issu de l'école libérale en arriver
à des réponses qui sont des quotas qui
sont globalement des réponses
coercitives non pas au point de vue
physique nos points de vue économique ou
parfois social ce n'est pas votre cas
mais chez d'autres c'est le cas donc on
arrive quand même un point où malgré et
certains ici sa première je suis attaché
à être une libérale on en arrive quand
même à un point donné où le libéralisme
ou le néolibéralisme dans le sens de
barbara siggers ne fonctionne plus
puisqu'on est obligé d'aller un peu à
l'encontre ou au moins 2 de cadenasser
les l'idéologie libérale pour résoudre
et points à ses cliques et l'écrit
climatique alors comment est ce que vous
vivez cette espèce de paradoxes en fait
le libéralisme ne fonctionne plus je ne
sais pas si c'est tout à fait exact mais
en tout cas le libéralisme ne nous
fournit pas tous les outils pour mener à
bien la lutte contre la dégradation de
l'environnement
j'en suis parfois nous personnellement
convaincu je pense que la préservation
de l'environnement est l'une l'un des
domaines dans lequel l'état doit pouvoir
intervenir l'état de pouvoir intervenir
parce que c'est un domaine qui est
générateur de fonds offrent de fortes
externalités négatives et que comme vous
le savez les externalités négatives ne
sont pas prises en compte dans le marché
et que tout un tas d'économistes
aujourd'hui se demande comment on
pourrait faire en sorte que ces
externalités négatives
autrement dit les dégradations que vont
commettre par exemple enfin que vont
entraîner la consommation d'un véhicule
personnel thermique d'une chaudière à
fuel ou que sais-je les dégradations qui
vont donc par ses consommations être
induites sur l'environnement donc je
pense qu'il est important de donner le
juste prix des choses et je pense que
les quotas carbone ou une taxe carbone
permettrait de donner juste prix des
choses permettrait de réfléter le vrai
coût de la consommation tant économique
que environnementale maintenant je je
comprends que vous puissiez y voir une
forme de contradiction et surtout la
manière dont la taxation carbone est
envisagé aujourd'hui la manière dont les
quotas carbone sont envisagées
aujourd'hui et quand même globalement
insuffisantes
elle a tendance à pénaliser beaucoup les
classes populaires et à être
relativement inefficace ayant entraîné
comme vous savez les gilets jaunes et
tout a pas de contestation
donc je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet très compliqué
la lutte contre contre la dégradation de
l'environnement c'est un sujet compliqué
parce que même pour les plus libéraux
n'ont que nous je parle évidemment de
ceux qui ne sont pas climato sceptiques
la plupart reconnaissent que l'état a
quand même un rôle à jouer
maintenant il en vient à définir quel
doit être le rôle de l'état qu'elles
doivent en être les limites
par exemple j'ai parlé du fait que
l'état
mais prendre part dans la construction
de grandes infrastructures nucléaires et
que sais-je pour que nous puissions
disposer d'une électricité bas carbone
n'est ce pas en contradiction avec la
volonté par exemple de vouloir
privatiser le secteur de l'énergie
comment régler ces deux impératifs c'est
des questions extrêmement intéressante
ça des questions extrêmement importante
et je pense que l'on peut conserver une
forme de liberté économique assez grande
tout en admettant que la liberté
économique ne doit pas être absolue
parce que si elle est absolue elle le
marché n'arrive pas à prendre en compte
toutes les sensibilités et le marché
n'arrive pas à gérer de lui-même
l'allocation des ressources vers un
monde à carbonne donc votre question est
très intéressante et je pense que le
libéralisme
je ne pense pas qu'il soit inefficients
mais je pense que en tout cas le
libertarianisme économique n'est pas la
voie pour lutter contre contre la
dégradation de l'environnement et je
pense que l'on doit admettre certains
mécanismes d'une certains mécanismes
coercitif au moins un peu pour régler ce
sujet après il y à de grands débats sur
quel niveau de dégradation on peut
admettre à savoir certains pensent que
4° et 5° 6 degrés c'est pas si grave que
ça et que du coup tous les mécanismes
que j'ai cités taxation carbone quotas
carbone individualisé ne serait pas
forcément nécessaire ne serait pas
forcément légitime parce que ce serait
créée au final des mécanismes qui ce qui
est coercitive des mécanismes qui
viendraient contraindre l'agent
économique danser dans ses mouvements
sans pour autant que l'impératif soit
justifiée et c'est quelque chose que je
retrouve beaucoup dans les milieux
libéraux une forme de dissonance
cognitive qui est de dire la lutte pour
l'environnement c'est bien
il faut qu'on investit dans le nucléaire
il faut qu'on fasse ceci il faut qu'il y
ait des véhicules électriques mais pour
autant tout l'état ne doit pas
intervenir
donc c'est le marché privé qui doit qui
doit rire des situations ces îlots de
muscles qui de trouver des solutions qui
doit les mettre en oeuvre qui doit déjà
de se réaliser et qui doit sauver le
monde
bah je pense et je sais que je me fais
beaucoup d'ennemis parmi les milieux
libéraux en disant ça je pense que ce
n'est pas la solution et je pense que
l'état quand même son rôle à jouer donc
je pense qu'il faut réinventer une forme
de liberté économique qui puisse ci
puissent coexister avec des impératifs
de préservation de l'environnement
et ça tombe bien monsieur compte c'est
le même que vous ayez cité l'état parce
que ça me permet de rebondir et on le
sent bien que quand même la cause
écologique la crise environnementale
elle est nécessairement collective on
peut pas répondre avec des comportements
individuels
il serait trop trop peu ambitieux par
rapport à la critique à laquelle on doit
répondre oui en fait dans votre vision
qui prône l'investissement dans les
technologies du futur pour décarbonés
notre économie et nos modes de
production avec un certain encadrement
de l'état si je si j'ai bien compris
pour pour ce faire vous semblez
finalement accordé beaucoup voire trop
de considération et de pouvoir aux
élites aux personnes qui sont en haut en
fait aux personnes politiques
économiques et aux élites dans une
logique verticale est ce qu'on fait je
me demande est ce que vous vous croyez
pas un petit peu aussi à l'échelon local
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas à la
transition écologique démocratique et à
la participation de tous les citoyens
parlent échange de bons procédés parce
que on sent bien également que plus la
transition écologique elle peut être un
formidable vecteur de 2009 de politique
et de bien-être en fait de bien les 300
mais de favoriser un bien commun un
objectif commun bien sûr l'idée ce n'est
pas de dire qu'on va avoir un super
administrateur qui va pouvoir gérer
l'état qui va pouvoir j'avais toutes les
productions qui va décider quelle
production n'a fonctionné a expliqué le
dr à fonctionner à l'hydrogène
non je pense que l'impératif de
décentralisation de la prise de décision
est nécessaire parce que sinon ans côte
ou dans des situations où on a
l'impression d'avoir des mécanismes
coercitif imposé de ne pas vraiment voir
les impacts positifs sur l'environnement
et où le citoyen lambda a l'impression
de ne pas vraiment avoir
son mot à dire dans le jeu je pense que
cette question de la démocratie
environnementale cette question de la
démocratisation du débat est extrêmement
intéressante et je pense que le débat
gagnerait beaucoup à prendre en compte
comment dire les idées de tous les
acteurs je pense qu' il faudrait mener
un grand débat sur l'environnement je
pense que les citoyens ont leur mot à
dire je pense que les collectivités
locales ont leur mot à dire et je pense
qu'en fait tous les échelons peuvent se
réinventer et tout le reste tous les
échelons peuvent participer
je pense que un grand état
centralisateur qui soit en plus au moins
un peu planificateur pourrait aider la
dégradation de l'environnement mais que
pour autant je pense que d'un point de
vue social d'un point de vue
démocratique ça posera un certain nombre
de questions
donc moi je pense que tous les acteurs
ont leur amour à jouer ont leur mot à
dire
je pense que les entreprises vont
innover les entreprises vont investir
dans la recherche d'entreprises vont
développer leur concept des
entrepreneurs vont avoir des idées vont
les mettre en oeuvre ses idées vont
pouvoir retrouver aux prises vont
pouvoir vont pouvoir se développer
je pense que la taxation carbone par
exemple permettrait de mettre un plafond
de dire enfin en tout cas une limite de
dire on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi
on doit respecter un certain nombre de
critères et connus de critères
environnementaux sinon bah on va devoir
prendre l'argent légitime pour pouvoir
leur investir votre part mais je pense
que l'état doit garder un rôle le plus
minime possible et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement compliqué les terrains en
garde un rôle le plus minime possible
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir laisser à tous
les acteurs la possibilité de s'exprimer
pour pouvoir laisser aux entreprises la
possibilité de s'exprimer pour pouvoir
laisser aux communes la possibilité de
s'exprimer pour pouvoir laisser aux
citoyens la possibilité de s'exprimer
donc je pense que votre question est
très intéressante et il est assez
compliqué d'y répondre parce que
justement on a beaucoup d'impératifs
qu'ils sont contradictoires
c'est à dire que pour régler la crise
environnementale ce serait très simple
d'avoir un état géant qui disent un état
ultra planificateurs qui disent tout va
passer à l'électrique
on va investir on va faire cession à
faire cela et au fond vous suivez ou
vous partez
je pense que c'est pas la voie à
réaliser je pense qu'il est très
important de de démocratiser le débat
qui est très important que les citoyens
aient l'impression de prendre part dans
cette réflexion commune pour cette
réflexion collective et qu on ait
l'impression tous collectivement d'avoir
un rôle à jouer et qu'on n'ait pas
l'impression d'avoir un état
technocratique dirigé par les élites
dont vous parlez et bien c'est déjà la
fin de cet entremets politique déjà le
sixième épisode de notre série merci à
vous monsieur damien cros elle-même pour
toutes ces réponses qui furent très
intéressante
merci à vous je pense que cette entrevue
permettra de favoriser le débat d'idées
comme ceux sur l'objectif premier de
scopeo favoriser le débat politique sur
des idées nouvelles des idées innovantes
qui favorise la la réflexion en effet
l'écho modernisme presque personne n'a
entendu parler en france et il me semble
sûre depuis que cette notion existe et
je pense que vous la défendre et très
bien bravo pour cette initiative que
vous aviez beaucoup que vous avez
entreprise ans en fondant votre groupe
de réflexion l'avenir le construit
l'avenir et je vous souhaite beaucoup de
courage de beaucoup de bonnes chances
pour pour cette initiative et plein de
points de belles choses merci beaucoup à
vous et je me suis quand même chose pour
pour scopeo merci bonne journée à tous
au revoir au revoir